on sort un petit peu on fait nos courses
nous-mêmes
on se trouve mieux quoi c'était pas
comme ça en Algérie
[Musique]
quand il faut livrer un chantier où il
faut aller chercher du matériel
je suis arrivé combien est-ce que vous
gagnez par mois
actuellement ça va je fais un
médicaments
ça dépend des heures qu'on fait et vous
avez assez pour vivre avec la famille
comme vous pourquoi ma foi comme la
plupart ils ont pas
un métier oui alors ils sont meneurs ils
font plusieurs chantiers ils travaillent
c'est vraiment deux moyens de moins
là-bas et
comment j'ai pas mal qui reste en
chômage il peut pas arriver c'est pas
possible de vivre une vie normale
s'il faut un manœuvre s'ils arrivent à
faire c'est pas moi 70 ou 80 000 francs
par mois il faut qu'il paye un loyer
vous avez le loyer ici cher alors
combien ce qui est le locataires ici
dans cet ensemble à peu près
63680 il y a beaucoup d'enfants oui
énormément nous sommes 5000 habitants
ici je ne sais pas à combien s'évaluer
l'enfant
comment sont-ils les étrangers
ils font de leur petit besoin ils sont
très incorrects vous avez des grandes
personnes
nous sommes malgré tout qui a besoin
d'une éducation qui n'est pas faite par
les parents
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a une boucherie pas
loin vous voyez qui est plutôt
enfin de chez eux et puis
on
fait un problème le fait qu'il y en ait
beaucoup comme ça dans les alentours
pour vous non enfin il y a surtout les
gosses
dans les couloirs tout ça il y a
beaucoup de bruit enfin
ça nous gêne pas quand même de trop ça
avec eux parce que par exemple voyez ça
ne change pas ils sont là toute la
journée les parents ne les tiennent pas
chez eux puisque c'est des grandes
familles alors ils sont dehors et on vit
en collectivité avec eux
combien est-ce que vous avez d'enfant
j'ai 5 enfants pour trois filles et les
garçons ils vont à l'école oui celui de
15 ans il va sur Colombie
et l'autre je sais pas il préfère faire
les dessins mais
il adore ça il fait bien il dessine bien
il fait des beaux dessins
mais si lire je sais lire mais je sais
pas écrire je sais écrire je fais des
fautes alors je préfère pas écrire
votre mari est venu en premier sans vous
n'est-ce pas pendant un certain temps ça
va lui faire maintenant 7 ans depuis
qu'il est là
moi je suis resté deux ans en Algérie
est-ce que ça vous a beaucoup changé
quand vous êtes venu ici en premier oui
ça m'a beaucoup changé et puis c'était
pas pareil que là-bas la banque sortait
voilée on sortait avec des trucs sur
vous savez des genres de
mouchoirs là comme mission le visage
quand je suis arrivé ici j'ai pas pu
sortir je me sentais toute nue je
pouvais pas sortir
je disais mon mari moi je sors pas
jamais je sortirai comme ça alors on a
vu la la fille qui a 10 ans elle avait 5
ans comme ça puis il me disait faut bien
l'inscrire à l'école
quand on l'a inscrit je commence à
sortir
qui sortait je rentrais mais quand même
je savais pas comment marcher mon mari
me disait mais toi droite il me semble
que tu es beau sujet
comme ça mais après c'est fini vous êtes
musulman est-ce que vous suivez encore
votre religion ici
ensuite
on fait notre carême on mange pas de
porc on va pas de vin mon mari de temps
en temps ça lui arrive il prend des
petits apéritifs quand on est invité
chez les voisins ou bien dans un mariage
alors salut les amis ils peuvent pas
s'en passer mais sinon vous trouvez tout
ce qu'il vous faut pour la nourriture
il y a des épices il y a de la menthe
verte il y a des du persil algérien là
comme de la chorba chez nous il y a un
persil spécial alors il y a tout ce
qu'il faut il y a il y a des pois
chichis alors
toute la nourriture
de rien
c'est le gros problème ici alors comment
ça se passe il y en a quelques-uns qui
sont très bien qui seront enfants et
surtout surtout envahi par les enfants
les enfants de très grosses
responsabilité on leur fait faire les
courses on leur donne de l'argent
il y a toujours un tas d'ennuis un tas
de soucis avec
ces gens avec ses gosses c'est
inimaginable il vide les poubelles il
casse les boîtes aux lettres il vous
déchire le courrier enfin
c'est incroyable incroyable
ça les gens qui viennent de l'extérieur
quand on leur parle comme ça ils nous
disent tout de suite vous êtes des
racines ou n'aimez pas les étrangers
mais il faut vivre dans le coeur du
problème pour se rendre compte de ce que
c'est c'est vraiment comme vous avez des
enfants vous n'avez qu'à les filmer dans
les écoles aller interroger les
directeurs les maîtres c'est
inimaginable
qu'est-ce qu'on dit à papa
non qu'est-ce qu'on dit à papa
[Musique]
je trouverai ça serait beaucoup mieux si
on pouvait les loger tous ensemble ils
ont des coutumes à eux et que malgré
tout il y a des cités qui ont été
terriens peureux ils sont ils sont
beaucoup plus heureux de se trouver
rassemblés que d'être mélangé avec nous
ça c'est sûr parce que vous voyez au
moment de la fête de mission
automatiquement ils ont l'habitude
d'avoir leur bête et de Dieu même et
nous c'est très désagréable c'est de
retrouver toute la tripaille dans les
boîtes aux ordures vous savez qu'ils ont
l'habitude jamais ils achètent un poulet
tué le tue même face au soleil pour
pouvoir c'est leur coutume mais ça
n'empêche pas qu'ils ont quand même leur
bête vivant pour les tuyaux moments de
quelle heure faites
[Musique]
et pourquoi est-ce que vous enfants
n'ont pas plus de contact avec eux
le besoin
ou alors si vraiment ils auraient des
contacts avec eux c'est un contact qui
ne peut pas durer longtemps c'est le
passage
je ne sais pas ils n'en ont jamais fait
part mais je crois qu'il doit avoir
quand même une petite différence entre
le français et encore ce soir de racisme
qui joue certainement
[Musique]
parce que
c'est pas
je crois que j'ai une tête qui leur paix
jusqu'à présent alors ça c'est vrai la
carrière du travail mais à l'extérieur
vraiment c'est dur
c'est pas tellement dur dur mais comme
il est toujours des réflexions
[Musique]
parce que moi par moment je suis
fatiguée j'étais supporte pas du tout
mais enfin je pense que par moment
c'était un petit peu énervant et
iranitant
mais enfin
je pense que c'est plutôt la question
des Arabes qui met le
parce que autrement je voyais les
Espagnols il y a des Allemands et tout
ça on s'entend très bien je crois que
c'est peut-être une question de
race ou peut-être qu'ils sont
dans des paysans
vous pensez qu'ils ne sont pas comme
nous
je vous dis il y a des exceptions je
crois que c'est tout ou rien
il y a pas de juste milieu
ils sont tout à fait
disons déplacés ils continuent à vivre
dans un pays sous le sous le ciel de
Paris il continue à vivre comme dans
leur Casbah au Maroc ou en Tunisie ou en
Algérie exactement la même chose je
pense que s'il y a beaucoup de malade
par exemple ou des trucs comme ça
maintenant je sais pas ce qu'ils
continuent à manger leur poids vont leur
courgettes leur piment et tout ça
[Musique]
combien de loyer ici dans cet
appartement et si on paye avant de payer
30 et quelques milles enfin c'était pas
cher mais après il y a des gens qui ont
réclamé ils ont dit il y a pas de raison
qu'il y a des familles qui sont nombreux
qui gaspillent plus d'eau que nous et
qu'on paye toujours le même loyer alors
ils ont placé des compteurs d'eau
maintenant chacun paye ce qui tue est-ce
que ça a beaucoup changé la vie que vous
avez ici avec celle que vous aviez en
Algérie
on se retrouve un peu libre
on sort un petit peu on fait nos courses
nous-mêmes
on se trouve mieux quoi c'était pas
comme ça en Algérie
que pour aller voir les parents enfin la
mère et le père les frères
les sœurs mais pas tout le temps
ne travaille pas
elle a déboulé à la maison puisque elle
peut pas se permettre d'aller travailler
lui permettrait
comme toutes les femmes ici en France
comment est-ce que vous voyez l'avenir
de vos enfants
[Musique]
Marguerite
Santos
[Musique]
on nous disait oui vous savez cette
école est quand même pas extraordinaire
le niveau est bas à cause des enfants
algériens etc etc et je croyais que
c'était vrai
et maintenant des exemples des montres
que des enfants de famille d'étrangers
maghrébin ou espagnol ou portugais sont
après être passé par cette école sont
maintenant au lycée donc je pense que le
milieu familial
a plus d'importance sur l'enfant et que
le rôle de l'école
je crois quand elles sont peu nombreuses
c'est assez facile parce que elle
s'intègre très facilement dans les
classes mais le problème est quand il y
en a une proportion qui est au dessus
quand même de 40 50%
elle manque beaucoup l'école les grandes
quelques-unes enfin nous faisons un
petit peu la guerre mais c'est assez
difficile parce que quand il y a une
fille aînée qui est à l'école des biens
quand la maman va la maternité la maman
est malade c'est la grande soeur qui
doit rester alors ce qui nous provoque
quand même un peu plus d'absence que
pour des enfants françaises enfin nous
essayons de faire la guerre et de les
empêcher de manquer
c'est assez difficile d'ailleurs sont
des familles nombreuses de 10 enfants 8
enfants et ça pose quelques fois des
problèmes parce que les enfants parler
arabe
un peu mais
le deuxième aussi mais le reste ils ont
pas
pourquoi
tu ne sais pas de temps en temps
mais commission toujours dehors avec les
gosses à l'école et tout ça
ne parle pas
je vais avoir mes trésors le 27 mai tu
travailles bien à l'école oui qu'est-ce
que c'est que tu préfères
comme métier
et à l'école qu'est-ce que tu préfères
comme matière le dessin le dessin
est-ce que tu parles arabe
un petit peu pourquoi tu parles pas
beaucoup
perdu la langue
et toi
qu'est-ce que tu veux faire toi quand tu
seras grande
[Musique]
parce que ma femme en Algérie
c'est simple
j'ai vécu d'accord j'ai vécu l'Algérie
j'ai vécu je suis né j'ai vécu là-bas
mais maintenant c'est fini c'est classé
et elle a deux enfants son mari est
ingénieur des Ponts et Chaussées ils
sont venus s'installer ici il y a 4 ans
on avait le sentiment que tous nos
contacts étaient très très dissymétrique
en fait c'est à dire que on allait chez
les gens ils allaient pas chez nous
et que il s'agissait pas d'annuler les
différences en disant qu'on était pareil
parce que c'était bien évident qu'on
n'était pas pareil
mais que pour réellement qu'il y ait des
bons approfondir des rapports d'amitié
il fallait il fallait partager quand un
certain nombre de choses dont la
localisation est dans le logement
et puis en fait bon c'était un petit peu
on ressentait ça plutôt qu'on se le
disait si vous voulez et puis il y a une
occasion et on a du coup on a très très
bonne relation maintenant enfin au début
c'était beaucoup plus ambigu enfin on se
regardait un peu on s'étudier et
maintenant elle me donne volontiers des
conseils enfin sur la manière de se
coiffer de se maquiller enfin pourquoi
est-ce que tu te maquilles pas mais je
voulais tu devrais te mettre du henné
alors je me suis mise du henné une fois
pour leur faire plaisir évidemment moi
j'ai des cheveux blonds alors au bout de
cinq minutes c'était déjà rouge
des relations très sympathiques parce
que c'est vrai qu'on peut les aider pour
certaines choses je pense pour les
problèmes de relogement ou évidemment ça
c'est compliqué mais même pour des
Français c'est compliqué ici il y a des
tas de papier à remplir etc même pour
nous quoi il faut nous on n'a pas les
problèmes de logement mais j'entends
quand il s'agit de remplir les feuilles
d'impôts c'est pas toujours facile alors
là bon ben on est ils viennent chez nous
bravo c'est très joli il n'avait jamais
vu opérer
bon qu'est-ce que je vais faire le
service là maintenant est-ce que le fait
vivre avec eux ça a changé le jugement
vous pouviez avoir de oui beaucoup quoi
c'est à dire quand je suis plus du tout
enfin
[Musique]
quand on quand on vient au problème
c'est tout basé sur du jugement
précisément on les perçoit à travers le
fait qu'ils sont différents de nous on
juge leur situation et puis on
s'aperçoit petit à petit quand ce
scandalisant à leur sujet
et ben on les on la ramène au rang d'un
from si vous voulez et moi c'est un truc
qui m'a beaucoup frappé c'est il y a un
an pour être discuter avec avec des amis
algériens qui leur disaient c'est comme
marrant actuellement à la télévision on
parle beaucoup de des problèmes
d'immigration mais vraiment il nous
montre pas comme des hommes quoi enfin
c'est vexant de se voir vraiment on a
l'air on a l'air de con quoi
et
en même temps alors c'est toujours des
attitudes un peu de pitié de parler pour
etc bon et c'est avec ça que va le
jugement
leurs principaux problèmes c'est pas des
problèmes de logement
non le logement c'est
c'est un des symptômes si vous voulez
que que saisie a souhaité française vont
on les voit mal logés
mais c'est en rien une cause ils
viennent en général d'une société non
industrielle donc la transformation de
leur culture qui est adaptée à cette
société en une culture adaptée à la
société industrielle c'est un problème
en soi et qu'ils ont ils ont besoin de
toute leur énergie finalement pour le
résoudre
pour ça ils ont trop de besoins de
sécurité de statut ils ont besoin de
sécurité économique etc ils ont souvent
quand ils viennent à projet de mobilité
sociale enfin ils sont venus pour
améliorer leur situation y compris leur
tournant là-bas il y a manifestement une
envie que les enfants réussissent et
cette envie alors elle est très larvée
parce qu'il voit pas toujours bien
comment il faudrait faire pour qu'il
réussisse etc mais cette envie elle est
très très présente si vous voulez
[Musique]
à quoi on se préparait quand même on
savait bien que ça se passerait comme ça
une fois
évidemment c'est toujours par période
des périodes où on est très fatigué ou
ça pèse un peu mais mais autrement non
mais on a l'habitude et puis c'est
tellement chaleureux vous savez ça nous
manquera certainement après c'est fait
très simplement on vient on t'avertit
pas on vient bon on sort on vient vous
rendre visite et c'est une chose qui m'a
frappé ça également c'est quand on est
malade tous les amis algériens viennent
prendre des nouvelles voir s'ils peuvent
vous aider et ça j'avoue que j'ai fort
apprécié parce que c'est une découverte
pour moi enfin du moment qu'on te
connaît on est un peu responsable de toi
tu es malade on t'aide c'est des hommes
bon ce que je trouve dégueulasse c'est
qu'il fait pas les moyens si vous voulez
de réaliser ce qui ce qui cherche ce qui
nous scandalise bon c'est que la société
française les utilisent à fond pour un
certain nombre de fonctions économiques
bon
pas travaux c'est connu mais également
toutes les industries en déclin c'est
beau tellement plus facile de vider des
étrangers avec des Français pour tous
les phénomènes conjoncturels c'est très
commode donc ils remplissent si vous
voulez des dates fonctions économiques
et je pense qu'en réalité la France ne
les paye pas leur prix et que ce prix
n'est pas au niveau de bâtiment normal
ou problème comme ça mais de leur donner
les moyens de réaliser
tous leurs projets enfin est-ce que ça
vous a apporté quelque chose de vivre un
HLM
de vivre ces de vivre ici oui je sais
pas si c'était le fait qu'on HLM le fait
d'être avec des amis étrangers le fait
d'être dans ce type de bâtiment qu'on a
fait HLM enfin oui ça nous a apporté
colossalement quoi
d'abord parce que
énormément de naïveté enfin
on y est venu en bon jeunes gens de
bonne volonté si vous voulez c'est un
truc dont on a du mal à c'est parti
et puis on essaie de laisser de côté ce
passionnel du départ pour pour creuser
quoi je crois que si vous voulez
il est important d'avoir dans les tripes
enfin des tas de compréhension de choses
qui sont pas vous donc vous savez que
c'est pas vous mais qu'on a assez
fréquenté pour commencer à les
comprendre
[Musique]